welcome back
so we are in our module on a machine
learning primer and we're breaking down
the different types of machine learning
and what goes into training a machine
learning model
so I want to dig a little bit deeper
into these different broad
categorizations of what types of machine
learning there are and what kind of
factors go into choosing if you're doing
a supervised classification problem or
an unsupervised clustering problem
things like that okay so this is a very
broad categorization and you'll notice
that the kind of large dichotomy is
between supervised and unsupervised
learning supervised means that your
training data has labels of the things
you're trying to predict with your model
unsupervised means you don't have labels
of the things you might want to predict
with your model and I'll point out that
there is this large kind of nebulous
gray area in the middle between
supervised and unsupervised learning and
in fact this is where a lot
of the most exciting research is
happening is in this this middle kind of
semi-supervised area things like
reinforcement learning generative models
um and so I'm going to dive into these
different classifications
really important Point oftentimes
nowadays machine learning has become
synonymous with neural networks but
you'll notice
notice subcategories of things you could
do for each of these types of machine
learning it's not like there's just one
big bold lettering that says neural
networks all across all of these
categories there are many many types of
machine learning model for
classification or regression or
reinforcement learning some of them use
neural networks some of them don't it
depends on your problem okay so let's
dive into kind of diagrammatically how
do we think about this dichotomy of
models here
so machine learning always starts with a
kind of system you're trying to analyze
that is generally generating data so we
have a system for me this might be you
know a wing that I'm modeling in a
computer you know simulation environment
and the training data might be the lift
and drag on that Wing something like
that okay so you have a system and it's
generating data and the different
dichotomies of what types of machine
learning algorithm you get to use depend
on the nature of this training data
so for example if the thing I want my
model to predict is part of my training
data if it is if I have labels on my
training data that have not just the
input data but also the thing I'm trying
to predict with my model which I call a
label if I have a labeled truth if the
answer is yes then I'm doing supervised
learning this is a whole category of
machine learning called supervised
learning where I am trying to build a
model to
re-capitulate a known labeled truth on
my training data so that in the future I
can deploy that algorithm on new data
and it will give me similar labels as if
it was labeled by an expert human
if I do not do knocks us to those labels
of what I want my output to be then this
is an unsupervised machine learning task
and this is much more like data mining
so supervised learning is more like
trying to mimic or automate an expert
system
unsupervised learning is more like data
mining I'm trying to learn patterns from
my data that I can then use to build
models to analyze future data
and then let's just zoom into this
supervised Branch for a little while
then I ask myself the question if I do
yes have labeled training data now I ask
is my label is the thing I'm trying to
model on the output is it a continuous
or a discrete variable and what I mean
by that is is specific so by discrete
label I mean if I'm trying to classify
between dogs and cats that is a discrete
categorization between two classes of
objects dogs and cats that's a discrete
label and those tasks supervised
learning with discrete labels are called
classification tasks I classify between
dogs and cats or between person a and
person B
if my label if the thing I'm trying to
model is a continuous variable like the
lift on an airfoil which can be any
numerical value and presumably
then that is what's called a regression
task I'm trying to regress to a
continuous variable like the lift or
drag on an airfoil and those regression
techniques there's lots and lots of
algorithms for regression there's linear
regression logistic regression gaussian
processes and so on and so forth and so
this is the main dichotomy is do I have
labeled truth data or not for example in
that example of a lift and drag
if I had a bunch of simulations of
different airfoils and I also had the
lift and drag for those simulations that
would be labeled so I'd be doing
supervised learning and I have a
continuous label so it's a regression
model that I'm building I would be
building a machine learning regression
model to predict lift or drag from
future airfoils
if I had that labeled training data for
dogs and cats classification I had a
bunch of images of dogs and cats and I
knew which ones were dogs and cats that
would be supervised learning and my
model has a discrete label just dog or
cat and so that would be a
classification task
similarly if I take this other large
path where I don't have labeled data and
I'm doing unsupervised learning I have
the same question is my do I believe
that the structure in my data is
discrete or continuous
and the way I think about this is if I
kind of imagined plotting all of this
data even if I don't have labels if I
plot all this data does it live in
discrete groups or clusters or is it
kind of continuously spread out in a
distribution if I believe that my data
lives in these discrete clusters then my
algorithm would be called a clustering
algorithm I'm going to try to learn the
Clusters that the data lives in
and for example if I had a bunch of
images of dogs and cats but I didn't
have labels I forgot or I lost my labels
I could still run it through this
algorithm and use a clustering algorithm
maybe to learn that there is a large
group of objects that are you know
correlated with each other and another
large group of objects that are
correlated with each other and I might
in fact learn that there is such a thing
as a dog and a cat
I wouldn't know which one's called which
you'd have to to choose the names of
these clusters
similarly if I believe that my data is
not living in these distinct groups kind
of these clusters but rather there is a
distribution of data that would be
called an embedding problem this one is
a little bit more nebulous and there's
not as well agreed upon nomenclature for
this I call it embedding sometimes you
just call this data mining in general or
distribution learning that's another way
to say it so for example if I had a
bunch of
um
data of flow fields from from you know
different airfoil geometries but I
didn't have the lift in the drag I might
believe that that data is still going to
follow a continuous distribution and so
even if I didn't have labels I would
still be doing this continuous embedding
to learn the structures of those flow
fields from data so those are the big
two dichotomies is your data labeled or
not that tells me if I have supervised
or unsupervised and is my label uh if is
my distribution is my data or its label
continuous or discrete that'll tell me
if it's a regression or a classification
or an embedding versus a clustering
algorithm
that's the main
uh thing to remember here and the types
of machine learning and there is this uh
very important Middle Ground that's
becoming more important every day if I
have partial labeling partial labeled
training data and this can mean a few
different things it can mean that there
is a larger label that I want to
estimate and I only have some of the
numbers of that like maybe I only have
the lift but I don't have the drag
or
or fraction of my training data has
labels maybe only 20 of my data has
labels that is also a type of partial
measurement and there's many many other
ways you could have partial labels or
partial measurements here and this is
called semi-supervised and it's kind of
this nebulous Middle Ground between
these two and here the dichotomy is not
necessarily discrete or continuous in my
mind it's more am I just trying to model
the system or am I also trying to modify
the system because in a lot of cases I
use machine learning models to then try
to manipulate the system for some kind
of a control objective or an
optimization objective
so if I'm only trying to model that
distribution from this kind of
semi-supervised partial labeled data
those models are generally called
generative models so Gans fall under
this category things like deep fakes are
essentially generative models based on
partial labeled data
if I want to modify my system if I want
to actually interact with my system and
change the system for some engineering
objective that would be for example
something like reinforcement learning
and generally speaking that involves a
feedback signal that actually takes the
output of my algorithm and then modifies
the system and changes how that data is
being generated in in closed loop okay
so this is kind of an advanced but very
exciting area of machine learning where
it's really at the intersection of
machine learning and control you're
actively modifying the system for some
objective and you're also building
models of that system as you're
collecting data and modifying it in real
time
my dichotomy here in supervised learning
so for example if I just want to model
the system that's the classical machine
learning we talked about before but if I
want to modify my system I can use those
same algorithms for optimization and
control
and so reinforcement learning I think of
as being kind of a partially measured
version of classical non-linear
optimization and control algorithms
again this is not a hard dichotomy this
is just something I found useful to kind
of straighten things out in my head some
of these lines are blurred depending on
what algorithm you use
here kind of if you want one key
takeaway this is the main canonical
picture of machine learning is that you
have supervised and unsupervised
learning and you have discrete or
continuous labels or discrete and
continuous data and that determines the
kind of four major types of tasks that
we typically think about In classical
machine learning things like
classification regression clustering and
embedding or distribution learning and
then there's this kind of fancier stuff
you can do in the Middle with generative
models and reinforcement learning okay
good so again notice I have not drawn a
neural network I haven't really even
talked about neural networks many of
these tasks you can solve with neural
networks many of these tasks there are
lots of other powerful machine learning
algorithms you can also employ depending
on what kinds of data you have and what
your objectives are so we'll talk about
all of that coming up thank you